humans might have built civilizations
but insects owned the world after all
over half of all known species are
insects so if they all suddenly vanished
you notice no more summers of singing
cicadas and flickering fireflies no bees
to pollinate apple cherry peach or
almond trees no one to make honey
a world without insects means a world
with empty grocery store shelves but
that would be just the beginning of our
problems now it's impossible to say
exactly what would go down but here's a
worst-case scenario of what could happen
if all the insects disappeared there are
a few insects most people would be happy
to see vanish like mosquitoes they kill
hundreds of thousands of people every
year by transmitting malaria West Nile
virus and other diseases but if they
disappear tomorrow we might actually
miss them there are over 3,000 species
and mosquitoes on earth all of which are
food to birds bats frogs and other
animals no more mosquitoes means these
creatures and the animals that eat them
could go hungry the same goes for the
dreaded cockroach a protein-packed meal
for birds rodents and even humans in
some parts of the world if we lost all
four thousand four hundred species of
roach entire ecosystems which struggle
to survive believe it or not we'd have
even worse troubles ahead since we'd
face a serious poop problem without one
of the world's greatest recyclers the
dung beetle you see history has taught
us exactly what happens when these
critters can't do their job back in 1788
the British introduced cattle to
Australia and these cows pooped a lot
each one poops enough to fill five
tennis courts every year but while the
dung beetles back in Britain would eat
and break down cow poo the native
Australian beetles wouldn't touch
stuff because they evolved to munch only
on dry fibrous marsupial dung so the cow
poop piled up by 1960 the cattle had
carpeted 500,000 acres of pasture in
dung that's enough to cover over half of
Rhode Island and while a little bit of
poop is great for fertilizer this ocean
of dung would flood plants with nitrogen
making it impossible for anything to
grow so imagine if all 8,000 species of
dung beetle plus other do dining insects
like flies
vanished worldwide the land would be
knee-deep in you know farmland forests
and desert would all collapse and
floating throughout would be loads of
corpses
see most animals won't eat dead bodies
that's where flesh-eating beetles aka
domestics and other corpse munching
insects come in over 500 species of
these grisly Undertaker's live worldwide
devouring dead flesh until nothing but
bone remains without them there would be
fewer custodians around to clean up the
mess sure there would still be hungry
vultures and bacteria around to help but
it wouldn't be enough so that's where we
can end up in an insect list world
starving to death while drowning in a
sea of poop and corpses